CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Thank you. Slightly
overestimated how tall I am there.
To my mum...
I knew from a very young
age that I was different.
We both did.
The way I'd sort my toys...
That I'd insist on different
plates for different foods...
And birthday parties
made me anxious.
And, by the time I was
four years old,
I became so sure that if I didn't
hide my differences,
people wouldn't like me.
So, I became a version of myself
I thought those around me
would accept.
I became a mimic,
copying other people,
imitating normal behaviour,
and suppressing anything weird.
For most people, these rules come
naturally, automatically.
Their faces match their voices,
match their feelings.
But I had to think about every
little thing.
In the end, I put so much effort
into this mask of normality
that nobody could even tell
that I had one.
When you're autistic, masking,
camouflaging,
it's a survival strategy.
It's to avoid judgment
or avoid bullying.
It's a way to fit
into the non-autistic world.
I have masked with everybody
in my life...
..including you, Mum.
I wanted to be the perfect child.
I wanted to make you proud.
But now...I'm tired.
It's exhausting pretending
to be normal all the time.
I'm beginning to think
it might be time to embrace my
authentic self,
to show you the
things you don't normally see.
But I'm scared.
I'm worried that
if I'm quiet and still,
and my face doesn't
match my feelings,
then you'll think
that I'm being rude.
I'm worried that if you see me
rocking back and forth,
or flapping my hands, then
you'll think that I'm not OK.
And I'm worried that if you see me
silent, unable to speak,
you'll think that I need fixing.
It might not come easily
for me straight away,
but I'm ready to be myself.
I hope you won't be disappointed.
I love you always.
Your daughter, Flo.
You all right?
- Love you.
- I love you.
I want to scoop up
the five-year-old you.
- Mm-hm. Me too.
- And say it's OK.
- Yeah?
- And if we could turn the clock
back, and I knew what I know today,
it would be... Maybe I would
have been able to give you
some reassurance about,
it's OK.
It's absolutely OK, you know?
- Yeah.
All through my childhood
and my teenage life
and my adult life,
you've been so accepting...
I'm going to cry.
..of everything
that I am.
- Because you're lovely.
I'm all right.
THEY LAUGH
But, like...
-  It's, er...
- It's scary being different.
It wasn't anything about you.
It was the world, really.
- No, but I...
Please, you know, you don't have to
mask in front of me any more.
- That's why... that's why I
wanted this video for you.
- Yeah.
- I wanted this film
to tell you that.
But it's been really hard to go,
"I've always been kind of acting."
Yeah.
I didn't expect to get snotty.
I know. Do you want a tissue?
Thank you.